then i thought to the prime minister
antónio costa executive vice president
of the francisco fernandes commission and
mayor of lisbon it
was a girl who joins us
[Music]
[Music] come
back now call the
younger guests talk and debates
students  from various schools and universities
come here to participate in this necessary
dialogue between those who have the power to decide
and those who want to see their decisions
taken
.  nuno gonçalves schools
there is an idea of ​​day school discovered
time and the representatives of greece
climate student sae east
competition são paulo should be distinguished
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm almost shocked
I looked for a city
[Applause]
these students this record
student games that are assumed  as the face of
all other young people who have nothing an
important voice in the world and the environment  What
remains is one more message for our
voices to be heard and it is with you that
these and so many other personalities
want to build and make decisions for the
future of the planet
.  taking into account
the r 7 results of school 34 and 25 it
is not expected that the nations of the world
managed to achieve the results
foreseen in the agreement pérez has to do
so that the head of state understands
that climate change is a
barrier to the development of science and
how can we oblige
governments to change their
environmental behavior
in the first place is it not true that
copies 24 and 25 went wrong
tokyo 24 steal it was possible and many
people thought that this could not be achieved it
was possible to attract it was possible to
remember the rules  of commercialization of the
agreement so it occurs or frankly
badly was the cup 25 14 25 and madrid was not
possible in the left angle  ment an
aspect of uol that has remained 24 14 and
that has to do with the carbon markets
and worse than that it was not possible to
commit especially the big
emitters is to neutralize carbon in
2050 but there is, as one says, a kind of
hope and  this reason for hope is a
combination of two factors the first is
pressure from the base is the fact that more and
more even in these
big emitter countries is to see a mobilization
of the youth to public opinion but
also more and more of the citizens of the
companies of the financial sector that
they understood that it is not worth having
shares in companies that produce click things that have
been coming for 30 years they have no
chance of continuing Espírito Santo there is
also an economic logic starting to
work in our favor and the second reason for
this mobilization and pressure
can be resolved
we started  to see the environmental issue have
importance elections that is great
the second reason has to do with the fact of
seeing a large economic bloc that
bet on neutralized carbon europe
and if europe is able to lead a
negotiation with other parties that
we will be there to support with
united states with russia with china with india
the other big emitters
i hope it will be possible to
reach the classic when the parents have
to  presenting his
determined national contributions is the new technician
who gives his commitments for the
coming years
I think it will be possible to reach the
classic with a dynamism enthusiasm and
commands are much superior to that
unhappiness about staying in madrid
while europe and with especially
windy course and  Compression of
public opinion and the pressure from now
on data corners in companies and in life have already
realized everything has to change because the
path we are following is a path
of
happiness our life questions even more terminal,
right from the school of são josé do hotel
back  taking into account everything that
happens on our planet is how long do you
think the gesture  it's trembling this
problem is so serious that
our planet is found the ship entered the river of
course it's clear what the source
is that's where i saw it in 37 limit of spain
antónio costa the work in 1773 neglect of the
economy stressed luís dom ávila luxury of
his  directional warning and tail cut
it is not our sites
river the rains 'ideal' xuxa did league
baseball foz the thread
played beautifully no and if you want to sell papers
from agre place and take care of the well-being of
our old thread do rio goiana and
that  everyone and in the
tokyo economic area tonight and today it's me and a sign
of status let's get crazy the next
questions come from the fly surfing movement
that we already have here a slight
manifestation that is part of the same
group with all right and now  I ask for the
task of taking into account the targets for
reducing greenhouse gas
emissions are not enough so that
when scientists are guaranteed
the necessary conditions for a
dignified life for future generations,
how can  world leaders say that they
are doing their best in the fight
against climate change when
they keep playing the big game at the end of the
three patients and giving more importance to
big capital than the citizens who
present well I want to thank you for the
question but maybe I want to answer  to the
questions that the question because we have to
debate the very clear form of the law that the
river has excluded it is not true that
search on google I searched on youtube and
see who wants the river tejo 30 years
ago 15 years ago 12 years ago
the  rio tejo
[Applause]
a threat curved at a
well-known moment in Portuguese life
when 30 years ago a candidate
for mayor of lisbon like myself
dived into the river tejo precisely to
show how impossible his life was
next to the hotel are  included
after that after hospitalization
by as many politicians who did not
want to pay the cost to carry out many
sanitation works in the city with
its  build its
sanitation system began to build its
stages
my support from the european union of the
structural funds to build this cetaceans
and we have a fundamental difference is that
we have croakers in the test
we already have dolphins in the tagus and in a
few years we will have one  bored in it will
be possible to dive without protection and
this is a very big evolution
we don't do everything in one way it does everything
in one go but also for hunter who
does everything alone in one go with end
by rule it's always a lie
trust more in  who promises a
consistent determined action so that
we can progress in the
results will join a second in the
second
a second sheet of gas buses
are not poisons
because I want to say that these new
buses are replacing
diesel buses that are more than 20 years old after 15
years  where there was no investment in renewing
the carris fleet
we are reducing emissions in 2021
these emissions will be 1 40% lower than
in 20  07 when the government handed over to the
lisbon council, carris
i would like it to be faster i would like it
but i feel that we are doing what we have
done in the right direction and the trajectory
we have is for us to reach the year 2030
as the renewal of the carris fleet wants
in 90% of emissions do
what we had in 2017
let's not talk about the airport
the very difficult and demanding topic there is no
possibility of having an airport be
green
the airport they teach don't contribute
don't represent a burden on the
environment our life but  I also don't know
yet for a country like Portugal is it
possible to go to our economy our
job in our life not to use
planes I don't know I don't know if everyone
here doesn't use the oral route or
is willing to live a life without
flying no  will seek to be able to
make that choice that's why
this choice is difficult this decision
that's why it's important to have a
decision that is difficult and demanding
we had to  I'm sure we're going to
improve the
environmental indicators along with the quality of life indicators.
Do what we have today. I don't believe
in anyone.
to get worse but the quality of the
night games in the city in the streets to
improve we introduced the pollution of the
correct one in the airport and to be able to have
a system that guarantees you in the
research second also the best
income championship
I have a great respect a great
admiration and a great  will take great
pride in the new generations in what they
do and do not expect, having already been
much more advanced than yours,
do different from what
young people do demanding politicians
demand those responsible to act also in
their more financial condition but that if
organize and mobilize people for this
action a little more a little more
attention  people are not all the same
explains that they are not all the same and the
options are not all the same
we are not in the stage in your
socks
here goes special and we know it is not the
same thing to have an
American administration committed to the action it was
matt that happened  the one we have
is not the same thing we have a government that is
working to reduce emissions and having a
government that neglects energy production
from renewable sources is not the
same thing having cities involved in
reducing emissions and
environmental policies or not having them  yes more
faster more hurry more consequent but
please don't get confused we all get together in
the same way think that everyone
acts the same way because that is
brazil zero of politics
the motto of the green capital is here it will be
written such and will choose choose to
evolve but  the first word chooses
a call because it is a choice
because it is an abstract choice to choose
between acting or not today choosing between
acting n  the right direction or not today in
the right direction in choosing to act to
fulfill our moral obligation to
protect the environment the intention of
future generations or not to do it but
let's not deceive ourselves it
's a choice we are not all on the same
side but there are many in the world in many
very historic sites everyone
here is all on the same side fighting
for what
the prototype is obliged to launch a
very active team
I think everyone was chosen not
taking advantage of the depth
that's why we are saying no with our heads
I want to go back  asking questions about the targets
contrary to what has been the targets
for reducing emissions of
greenhouse gases are not enough
according to scientists
the necessary conditions for a
dignified life are guaranteed future tragedies
how can world leaders say that they
are doing their best  in the fight against
these issues when keeping in the game
of the big polluting industries and giving
more importance to the big cap  ital and the
arrival today represent you know what I
think what ends up answering
your question well is given what
is happening in the various countries and in the world
the reality is very different is that
at the moment there are countries that are
increasing  their emissions just that they
are opening coal plants
that's what we are restricting they are
reducing the environmental requirements
collectively the emissions countries and look at
the projects and the indications that
are moving in that direction but there are
others with that are reduced
emissions accordingly  because they committed them and
other countries like portugal that are already
reducing emissions more than what
they committed
that does not mean it does not mean
that we have a word of
satisfaction here for the judgment not because the
world wants to take part in this battle that
in the whole of  what we all
insist on is that we are going to have to
continue on this path in the country in
lisbon and this is the motto this reason the
verd capital  and winning this battle
we do our part i know it will know it
will come out that no one
expects to grow in the united states of
america coal power stations fight in this
not to do in large quantities that in
lisbon the fall alone can compensate for
this increase we can't but  I want to
have a clear conscience clear
new generations plants I mean we
did our part we are the
first city to set the goal of
carbon neutrality in 2050 and we
are on the way to achieve it
and we are aware that by walking  of the
carriage
we are going to have to do more than
was our part our commitment to
compensate is that those who are not doing it
but looking carefully is that the world today is
very different
the regions of the world are advancing in
a different way unfortunately in the  in europe and
in particular in portugal and in the back
street what we have today is to reduce emissions
when in other parts of the world they
are increasing
no not all  the same as a
political choice and this choice is here for the
environment and environmental sustainability it
would now be your turn to
ask the presence of the minister with for
lisbon to congratulate receiving awards
like capital verde knows there are
projects such as the expansion of
portola airport that made the  already
insufficient goals promised by your
government and attainable
thanks for this question to help
explain the issue of the airport bringing
one of the most feathery issues place on the
other side oak that does not mean
zero emissions means that the emissions
that exist will be a
thoughtful segment of  way is to see neutrality
compensates for emissions it will not be
possible according to what we have
today the technology and total lighting -
emissions and that is why the plan for
climate action and heating came from vasco
conservative
we took into account the childish technologies
that already  there
are we didn't even have any account and it was
a technology that hasn't yet  there is a
desire to throw the body at the beginning of the
century until 2050
nothing will change
even where they will continue to
believe that they currently conclude is a
scenario but nothing says possible because
most likely it will happen to the
11 years old what also happened to the
others but it changes when the
technology was excluded and probably
beer in 2050 will not be as controversial
as the sky but let's admit that nothing
happens that neither the management nor
my children's generation nor you will be able to
produce planes subway in the serve the
french have sensors the new airport
will produce two  they had 2 million
tons of co2 per year 2 million sides
co2 per year
now here is a goal that we have in
addition to achieving neutrality rock I did not
prove zero emissions because the emission of
3 million per cent to 10 of co2 that is 3
million side the meetings  already behave
exist are included the two million
that currently due to the problems that
will issue that resulted from the expansion of the
airport  the one for lisbon and besa
now this is the framework and therefore we
did with and they reach neutrality is
unique we are already taking into account the
expansion of the port and the expansion of the
model what can happen from here to there what
can happen from here to there  is that the
technology is the year and therefore there should be
less emissions with the airport in 2050
than we are today 1st
so if this is the worst possible scenario it
is the scenario in which nothing changes nothing
happens nothing better and even so we will
manage to achieve the changes by
now they will come but why not use the port
we want a new airport in the supply region we
encourage a country that has the
geographical position of portugal is not
in the center of europe
so you can easily replace
traveling by plane by calling
with boy for example is not it  a country of
less fortunate people in a country in
central europe a country with 10 million
brazilians but yes, we are portuguese
spread all over the world in america,
africa, asia a little  the whole of
europe cannot fail to have more of
this strong prohibition between us and our
allies a not so much animal is that the
country beyond the continental territory
is distributed projected in the atlantic thing
only makes the defenders of the misery still
assure by way  airline to contribute
attributed to physically is not
assured
portugal is even one of the most
pending countries most pending of
air transport to ensure
territorial continuity cruise makes
to ensure connection with the thousands
of children who pass through there are already
few spaces worldwide and also
I wanted to say quite frankly the
next moment comes when you observe
the services but I mean quite
frankly alone I don't besides the
speech of the tourism company
I want very close without borders and one
of the athletes without borders is 12 to
circulate as refugees  as immigrants
but also by tourists
so what we like to censor
are better than demands
both  esentials
regarding airports
regarding planes
we have to work hard over the
next few decades to improve
technology like in two times
right here in 2050 disarm an
airport and admit 2 million on the co2 side
per year
but what I wanted to say is the following
even if  this is not possible even
if we don't make it by 2050
even so with this pressure we will
reach catholic authorities in the
terms and in the terms that they don't promise and
that's what we have to do
unfortunately we have organized and at the same
time we are more first air transport
we have the biggest  be careful that others
leave power be much more efficient
from an energy point of view because we
are careful to always have all people
on renewable energy
we have hydraulics for our luggage
we have a government with the only one and we
have above all in parading and these
three renewable energy
sources we really want to become one of the
great production platforms  tion of
rogélio
v hydrogen green gray two things
needed and we have water in the sea in
abundance and it needs cheap energy and
we have the air that said
cheap and we are currently
working with the government on the environment
saying to develop a
large city  platform for creating
hydrogen money can serve the
rest of europe it serves
individuals with 25 natural gas opel
three always through maritime transport
and therefore we will compensate for
what we will have to be like this me
only that air transport the other
we can earn  and neutralized
particularly from an energy point of view
and this is the challenge that we
have to overcome together and we will overcome
but thank you very much for your question
the team unfortunately putting our
planet this week the weather also today
I invite my guests to
start studying
thank you  studying this is a
social network we should win
invite you to continue chatting